hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now a lot
of you guys we're mad at me cuz I didn't
actually hit use on this doll here so
this is for real haha I've never hit
this before oh that's so cute I don't
even know if I can make that scream if I
tried oh that's so cute
Wow okay I'm gonna take you with me I'm
putting you on big box berry but I'll
come get you in a bit because I don't
have time for big bucks Barry hey look
my shits back okay so what I got a word
bah bah bah did I not doc bumble bumble
button oh ha ha ha
bumble bite you can't run away from me
like that
you'll get lost ok so I know where the
seed locations are they may be a bit of
a [ __ ] to find but at least I know
where to go for them so the membrane
seed the membrane tree in fact is
actually somewhere in the grand reef so
I'm gonna go find that right Oh hidey
hidey hidey ho are you what I'm looking
for
oh my god you are aren't you hey hi Bice
can you oh oh so this is the first of
four ingredients I didn't see this in
biome in there so I didn't think it was
gonna be there hey hey [ __ ] spinner
losses whoo
whoa why am i inside of you where is he
what are yo OH
all right anyway so we got the first of
four the other three are in various
locations throughout the entire ocean of
subnautica now conveniently for me two
of them are easily accessible the third
or the fourth it's going to be a bit of
a blue to be able to get because it is
rare to say the least
I believe there's only about there's
only a handful of the last plan in the
entirety of this ocean which is kind of
boy oh boy it's good to be back in
bubble but it has been a while since
I've been up and exploring the upper
areas of subnautica oh here here is the
crevasse alright so down in this curve
vas is something that I need I always
hate going in this areas because it's
just so unnatural like everything any
air just looks so freaking weird I
believe this is what I'm looking for
isn't it isn't this feather
it's Gabe's feather now I don't know why
these are gonna use the hatching enzymes
but hey I'm not gonna question it when
it's right in front of my face
got that didn't bumble but then you go
off indeed but oh okay so I got two
seeds which is good because I believe I
only need one of each of these and none
of the others now the third one is in an
interesting little interesting location
it's actually on the back of the reef
backs so it's a good thing I'm not
bringing big box burial say last child
support from him but don't worry about
that I'm gonna go ask very nicely if I
can borrow some of the other things
from the back of their ass ah this is
normal dark this is Vance darkness hello
oh hi hello oh there you are
who's looking at the moon you're just so
pretty you know whenever I see the moon
I figure you cuz you're so equivalently
beautiful hey you mind if I scrape some
seeds off the back of your ass um I'm
just gonna assume that it's somewhere
here and try to scan what I can hey
don't mind me back here you just if you
feel a tickling sensation that's just me
getting frisky don't you worry all right
so that's not it red quartz there you
have some red wart back here lady I
don't know how to tell you this but I
expect you with another present ooh
pulsating no it's nothing oh that's part
of you fooled the Pyrus why are you so
far away add this alright alright so I
don't know if you're just lacking in the
seed Department but I'm gonna go I'm
sorry I have a boyfriend
how about you hey big sexy what you got
on your ass oh yeah hey that looks
special is that what I'm looking for
yeah bruised bruised that's what I'm
looking for Oh give me some of that
Rouge baby oh yeah what was that
what hit me what oh you okay fine [ __ ]
you all right let me breach here because
oh it's so tough urk it's so
unquestionably dark oh I guess I'll make
it back towards my life pod which I
can't believe is still floating after
all these years that I've been under the
water and if the Sun could come up oh is
that the Sun coming up oh thank you that
is already three of four we are almost
underway to be able to get to the
hatching enzymes but the last one
my people oh excuse me were you just
having some private time with that
pillar I'm sorry for disturbing you
oh I can see oh I can see ain't that
lovely oh and it looks like my life pot
oh my god what happened to my webcam
holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] okay I've returned from
being abducted by aliens apparently I
have no idea what happened to my camera
freaked out I thought it was the capture
card but no my camera was just borked I
don't know why but if it happens again
oh well this is the mushroom forest near
the couch zone but I gotta be in the
couch zone to be able to get it and I
have a funny feeling it's gonna be very
hard to spot I have a vague idea of what
it looks like kind of thin paper II
doesn't look like you'd put up much of a
fight everybody keep your eyes peeled
I'm gonna need your help on this one
just shout really loudly
don't even bother writing in the
comments to shout woah hey hey hey hey
hey I don't like the look of you yeah
I'm calling you foot [ __ ] ugly seems to
be a lot of life a lot of activity
happening down in the deep blue sea whoa
hey whoa sorry
Oh woah you just appear out of nowhere
I'm just coasting along Oh Lottie
[ __ ] dawn then you pop out of nobody
let's see anything there sorry just
trying to get by man just trying to get
by I mean I know you were too and now
you're dead but you know I consider
myself to be very important a youtuber
don't you know and as a youtuber I have
an excessively high opinion of myself
hey hey get out of the way all the way
all the way I think I see it is that it
that looks like it wait hang on see
crown is that it I have no idea that's
what I'm looking for but I think it is
if it is right I got a hurry in the
bucket Oh get it in the bucket okay all
right we're off
we've got all four which means that we
can make the hatching enzyme I literally
think we don't need anything else but
those to be able to hatch I mean this is
it I mean this is it this is this is it
oh this is what I've been waiting for oh
my god some resolution to this and I
don't know if there's gonna help me get
off of this island but it should help me
at least cure the virus which means that
I can afford more time which is the
biggest crisis in this game right now
this disease is gonna kill me no matter
what I do the life in this like I
actually learned that the life around
this uh and around this base the only
reason why life is here is because the
sea Emperor has been able to transfer
some of it so some of its enzyme 42 to
the surrounding waters of this area
because of the alien precursor tubing
system that allowed the peepers to go
around everywhere else on this entire
planet is dead there is no life not a
scrap of it anywhere to be found
elsewhere so all of my dreams of there
being giant leviathans bigger than we've
ever seen before in the distance
that can't happen that won't happen it
just won't happen because every other
area on this entire planet was killed by
the core our virus can I send my C Mon
3r can i please please tell me bumble
but can come with me hey please tell me
bumble but snot about to be crushed Oh
ah I'm here that was scary
but I made it okay okay am i seamoth is
not exploding so that's good to know
okay hey Emperor I'm back and I've got a
special present for you that I think
you're going to like very much so if I
take all this and all that and switch
out this toy car for good luck which one
of those took some titanium in there and
then one more of this
I have everything oh this is it
alright I don't know what there's gonna
lead to it might be anticlimactic but I
don't know
insert hatching ends oh wait no do I
have to make that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] ah I
gotta make it odd I'll be back I'm sorry
yes the wink
I'll be back I'm sorry I forgot about
that
I forgot I gotta take my seamoth through
there again the really questionable
decision of sending the CMOS all the way
through here we go anyway though
whatever what could happen the base of
the Aurora Oh Oh such a worrier don't do
it five enzymes that normal sploosh get
some peepers and eat them boomerang some
piss to wash it down
squid bah bah okay we're ready to go
let's go in this bad boy scuba dooba
dooba dooba dee doo this is it
visit now it's it it was it before I got
y'all hype for no reason but this is it
I have the hatching enzymes I don't know
what they're gonna do and I don't know
if it's actually going to be final I'm
prepared to be disappointed in that
regard but I came all this way and I did
it of my own volition with you guys's
help I got these hatching enzymes I made
it from the very first crash all the way
to now and this may not even be the end
because I still haven't escaped but if
it heal
me and I'm gonna take off my gloves just
so I can see what happens but if it
heals me and if I look at my hands oh
it's not so bad but if I scan myself I
bet I have
yeah I'm infected but let's see what
happens
hi oh hi oh oh oh I'm trying to scan you
so badly oh it's not working there we go
oh oh oh my God look at him go
they're tiny and adorable oh they're not
a hundred percent functioning prop all
go to your mama well go to your mama
oh it's beautiful oh it's beautiful it's
beautiful mama it worked I can't believe
it worked
what was that
oh oh they're going to mama
oh oh they're going to mama Oh
my young are swimming for the shallows I
thank you
their freedom is my end perhaps next we
need I will be an ocean current I will
carry seeds to new lands or a creature
so small it sees the gap between the
grains of sass I forgot about that and
what is that
Oh baby Leviathan enzymes not yet
implemented man I got chills from that I
had goose bumps ah so by saving the
babies you the mom dies it's like it's
like with a squid like the parents die
every time they're their babies are born
like they spend so much energy just
surviving long enough for the next
generation I don't want to leave just
leave but the babies are already gone I
guess you just follow the glow she's
been here for a thousand years she's
been holding on to life for a thousand
years hoping beyond hope that someone
would come along and save her children
that's so sad and so beautiful at the
same time I guess I just gotta say
goodbye
[Music]
honestly emotional about that I honestly
am like if there's one thing that always
gets me like in terms of like emotional
stuff it's it's always the concept of
sacrifice so I highly doubt I highly
doubt that they're over here yet I'm
just trying to glance around I'm just
trying to glance around hope I don't run
into him like that that's the story even
though of this work did this work nope
still infected because I pissed myself
because it hasn't been implemented yet
and I think I really am happy that you
guys waited with me for that because it
was it was a big decision to be like be
at the precipice of that and be like hey
I could do this right then and there but
it wouldn't been worth it and even now
like it's not fully implemented but
that's so much better than what I was
gonna do like if I had cheated and you
know sawn like seeing the end there but
anyway that is the end of subnautica for
now again like with the last time I left
this series were waiting we're waiting
for the full release of the game and now
that I've seen this you know I think now
I will I'll wait for the full release of
the game because it's only gonna be like
September until the game actually gets
fully released so it's not gonna be that
long but it'll be long enough to give
this a breather and let this rest
because I think this is the best ending
that we could have hoped for in an ideal
world we would have seen how you know we
would have been cured and we would have
seen the children playing here in the
safe shallows and who knows they may be
here but that's better than what we were
gonna leave them and I feel good about
this
I really do so thank you everybody so
much for watching subnautica will return
when there is the full release of the
game and thank you so much for joining
me on this journey I hope you enjoyed it
as much as I did and I hope you're
satisfied with it until there's more yet
to come so thank you again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]